welcome to the February 24th meeting of
the Health Human Services oversight
committee I do not believe that we have
a quorum so I would suggest we dispense
until next time with the reading of the
minutes since we can't vote on them
one of the great features of this
okay
foreign since we have a quorum please
take the minutes from the February 3rd
meeting look over them very quickly to
we're reading over the minutes from last
a comment representative Edwards
um okay it's not that big a deal I don't
think but before I
left that day I think we were on the
child fatality Review Committee and I
thought we had a decent discussion uh as
short as it was regarding
um
doctors giving advice on
Firearms do you think that that's
covered adequately in the first
paragraph
the director gave a report on suicides
and what the committee has found the
results indicate suicide by hanging
Firearms what would you propose we add
as a sentence that would
I I I'd say that we we opened up a
cautionary note that uh
clinicians
ought to be judicious and when they
counsel
patients and ask questions of their
Pediatric
patients regarding gun possession in the
house
care to attribute that to somebody
because I don't
I didn't participate in that sentiment
and I don't want to be associated with
it that was me okay
that was definitely me if that's
attached to your name then I have no
objection at all to adding it to the
minutes right
and later when I talked to Miss Tilly
she had a great reason for why it was
important if the child is suicidal for
example it's a perfectly great
conversation to have but but still the
clinician and patient relationship is
really reliant on trust and some
anything else yes representative can you
repeat how you'd like that said in a
minute so I can catch it if if you'll
allow me I'll uh I'll I I can't
talk and think but the words jump out of
would you accept a cautionary note was
raised that clinicians be judicious in
asking gun possession questions in
uh their young patients
plural possessive home no because that
attributes that sentiment to all members
of the committee
don't share them representative asked
representative Edwards asked
I don't think he asked I think he stated
because I was leaving I I did state it
and I think it ended up in a
conversation after I left
a cautionary note
that clinicians be judicious in asking
gun possession questions of their young
patients is home
okay
seeing hearing nothing else could I have
a motion to approve the minutes with
that Amendment
second representative McDonald moves
representative Edwards second all in
favor
aye opposed
thank you the minutes are accepted
and now the reason we all drive here the
update from
the commissioner
lessons from Laurie
good morning that's quite a expectation
um well I good morning uh committee I
have a pretty robust
update uh this morning via channeling uh
director Henry Littman from our Medicaid
Program we'll be talking about the
unwind coverage as well as covering some
of the adult Dental the recent
legislation and some rate discussion so
that's a pretty robust discussion I'm
going to have Henry and Karen come up to
start to talk about the unwind of the
though this is not a good place to
good morning again Henry Littman
Medicaid director for the record
good morning my name is Karen Hebert I'm
the director for the division of
economic stability thank you
so I just open up
um and
just sort of set the set where we are
um as you know
um
the Medicaid Program today has the
largest enrollment I think ever in the
history of the program because of
the continuous coverage requirements
first under the federal Public Health
Emergency and secondarily under the
Consolidated appropriation act which was
passed at the end of the year that act
um
bifurcates continuous enrollment from
the public health emergency and defines
a a date certain in which states can
begin to unwind
um
I'm happy to report that
before states can actually initiate this
activity they have to go through a
process of sharing with
CMS centers for Medicaid Medicare
services that they have the systems and
things in place in order to do this
that states could begin at the earliest
disenrolling people April 1st I think
New Hampshire is in the top quartile and
being able to begin early and that many
states are going to need mitigation
plans before they can begin so I think
in terms of Ready set go in terms of
being able to to begin the process where
physician and actually are are executing
as we're speaking today the process is
starting to move
just in terms of the
the slide deck uh I'm not going to try
to cover every single slide in this deck
and I think you can just kind of run to
slide five gives you the state of
enrollment as of January 30th
um
let everybody catch up with make sure
that the number is kind of small on the
everybody's with that with me at this
point
um the standard Medicaid Program has
grown by about 20 percent since the end
of February of 19 basically the
effective beginning of when the
continuous enrollment began in March and
the granite Advantage program has grown
86 percent
um in total the whole program has grown
by almost 40 percent 39 percent
um where probably if you look at our
enrollment today we're just over 250
000.
um
so just on the bottom of uh slide six
there's some important definitions here
today the continuous enrollment is
protecting just under 102 000
individuals were not for the continuous
enrollment would would no longer likely
be on the program
um they're sort of fall into two groups
of people one is the group of people
that
um
were were not for the for the continuous
enrollment and not completing their
eligibility
um paperwork would have been disenrolled
and that's about
um not how the slide coming ahead on
that that's about 73 000 people almost
and then there's a group called pending
and eligible people who did complete
their redetermination
and um currently
um are protected in the sense that
they're they're they're no longer
eligible but are protected by continuous
enrollment so they may be over income as
so if you turn to the next page of
a question would you mind taking a
question would you prefer to wait me to
wait till you finish I'm happy to go
however the committee would like so am I
a right in thinking that the pending and
eligible are the people who we are
unwinding
or that we will be unwinding first or I
think I'll get to that one second thank
you so
just to to get the population
um for you in terms of that what I just
sort of described is at the top of the
page is described as in the um
counting individuals if you look on
opposite side it's counted as households
our approach to working this is actually
to do it by household because why make a
household go through three or four
different redetermination processes to
do it as a as a group on the bottom uh
slide eight which is sort of the purple
and green and blue colored slide it's
basically who of that hundred and one
thousand where they where do they exist
and as you might expect because the the
largest growth was in the granite
Advantage Program the largest group of
people that have had a protected status
are people in the the Medicaid expansion
the concerning group for us I think is
the children the almost 35 000 children
where
um you know we've done significant
Outreach and actually you know Karen's
team
um maybe Karen you could speak to all
the Outreach that you've done but we've
some states stopped doing regular work
we never did
um and we got over 32 000 people to
voluntarily complete their
redeterminations and now over 2400
people have told us
um based on proactive asking if you will
um do you need Medicaid coverage anymore
and people come forward and said we've
got something else we don't need it
anymore so we've been able to to deal
with
um you know over 34 000 cases which that
hundred and hundred and 2000 would have
been almost a hundred and you know
thirty five thousand hundred thirty six
thousand otherwise Karen you might share
a little bit about what your team has
done and they've done a great job sure
morning
so this for the Department I oversee the
Bureau of family assistance is one of
the areas of the division and that
contains all of the staff who conduct
the eligibility processing so they
receive applications they receive
renewal applications and process all the
verification
documents for folks to determine their
eligibility
so
that particular it's a large group of
Staff they are in all of our district
offices across the state and I will say
that I'm incredibly proud of them for
the work that they are doing to get
ready for this this is all about
operational Readiness because we've
never done this before this is
unprecedented volume of work that we are
anticipating from our constituents from
our citizenry Medicaid beneficiaries who
we've been trying
uh a number of strategies to reach out
to each of these individuals to make
sure that they understand what's
happening during the continuous
enrollment process but even more so now
that we have a date where that
continuous enrollment is ending
so the Outreach that we've conducted
we've reached I believe over 40 000
families that our staff have reached out
to to make sure that they are aware of
what they need to do that they
understand the instructions we've been
working with
a number of the providers as well across
the state we have office hours if you
will for them a number of them that they
can contact us to talk about the clients
that we have in common to help them so
we're actually having a lot of the
provider groups help us as well to do a
lot of this Outreach
because we can't do it alone so we've
really been partnering significantly
with those provider groups to make sure
that they can help us do a lot of this
Outreach
um
we've also been putting together some
new workload distribution plans to end
up process processing as much as we can
as quickly as we can this is all about
capacity and how do we increase that
capacity to make sure that nobody
or as very few possible people as
possible experience any kind of Gap in
coverage or lose their coverage we don't
want people to learn or figure this out
while they're in the checkout line at
the doctor's office or the pharmacy so
these are concerns that we have had all
along and trying to prepare
for this process for this volume we've
done a lot of simulated activities as
well just to test our own Readiness and
foreign we've also engaged the Managed
Care organizations in this and and part
of what we've done is we've given them
lists of their where they have a patient
relationship
um and where a like a mental health
center or a federally qualified Health
Center in our area agency a hospital
what have you
um we give them a list of their patients
with what their redetermination date is
and what type of of things are they
missing to complete their
redetermination and and we've been doing
this um you know for going on two years
now trying to get people to do it
voluntarily in advance as well as now
get into this in a moment here part of
the the process that states have to
follow to um if you go to topless next
page top of that slide 11 on the right
hand corner is that to earn the extra
several matching percentage the federal
medical assistance fmap as we call it it
which
up to this point the additional Federal
monies we've received has allowed us to
cover the cost of the the extra
enrollment so the state hasn't had to if
you will incur extra
General funds to support the program but
that extra money is going to be
phased down and which is why because New
Hampshire
compared to some states like take a
state like New Mexico as an example they
have a much higher Federal matching
percentage because their poverty level
is among the highest in the in the
country so states that are more
um well New Hampshire has a good economy
right and and some good wage here that
we're we're at the minimum fmap for
standard Medicaid which is 50 all states
get the 90 for the for the expansion
population but in order to to actually
draw these funds you have to follow
somewhat of a guidance and the guidance
is intended to return to normal
operations in the sense of that we don't
want a big bolus of redeterminations all
in one month that we're not going to be
able to handle in future years they're
trying to get states to get back to you
know having a normal distribution so
what we had to do
is of those people that's that 73 000
roughly of individuals we had to map out
new redetermination dates for them so
that if you go to the bottom of slide 14
is this is a sort of the spread of how
we get back to normal within a year's
time and I'm gonna talk a little bit
more about this on a subsequent slide
but basically this is part of our plan
that we had to have approved showing
that we had a plan to get back to normal
in terms of a reasonable distribution as
well as followed other things like
making sure that we followed
um
you know the normal noticing the normal
decisions giving the right of appeal all
that kind of thing process procedural
things that people are entitled to for
rights uh
um and I'll jump over to
um
the top of uh I'll skip the next page
because we've kind of talked through
that the slide title percent of
population with no provider payments the
way
um
and and then the monthly distribution
these are really two important slides if
you to to understand kind of what's
going on
um so when we needed to distribute the
population over a one-ninth um basis we
said what's what's the way to go about
this so that
um we did it sort of on a risk basis you
know some states are just doing it you
know just across the board we try to
take an additional level of sensitivity
both from a financial and a clinical
perspective so what we did is we
analyzed all our enrollment and looked
at trying to put first those people who
haven't used health care very much or at
all and so they're more likely to not be
harmed by being disenrolled versus for
example someone who's a hemophiliac or
um has other you know serious medical
conditions that moving those people
further out into the
um into the unwind because they're most
likely to likely qualify and a gap in in
health care coverage is more likely to
do harm to them
and then this all falls down to this
uh what we is our estimated plan of how
this is all going to work out
chair recognizes representative Edwards
for the question thank you Mr chair
thank you Mr lookman um we're going to
hit this in more detail on division
three so so I'm not looking for a
detailed answer here but I can't help
but to think as you're going through
this that one this is tremendous work uh
but then I get into wondering about
the Manpower required to be planning
this and executing this and the
availability of any I.T system support
that's making it easier or harder for
you
and and then and then that leads me into
thinking well what about the mcos how
much are the mcos having to invest
Manpower and time into this as well and
I I guess I guess the kind of answer I'm
looking for is
um
is this really pushing your organization
your manpower to where you're largely
maxed out on your capacity to manage
this much change or do you feel like you
are doing this easily in stride
so I guess it's sort of a two-part
answer I think we've been working this
since July of 2020 we've been planning
and fortunately a lot of the Investments
that the state had previously made in
its eligibility system that
um the reason we're sort of ready to
begin anyways is that that we're
leveraged off what we've had we've been
I think we're in a good shape what
what's the unknown for example is
um is like the appeal process how many
people are going to
um appeal are we going to get is there
going to be a place where we
um uh
you know get held up a little bit
because of of people just taking
advantage of appeal rights when there
may not be any
um ability for them to maintain coverage
so I guess our answer up to this point I
think it's been you know stressed us but
I think that we've tried to manage this
so that we don't get overwhelmed which
is to say since we've never done
something this big we do have some
concerns that we could as we you know
particularly at the beginning when we're
moving a lot of people off you know do
we have the workforce to handle all the
incoming information but we've tried to
beef up for that
if I may please
thank you for the question so there has
been a lot of concern about our capacity
to be able to process what's coming so
we've been working very hard at coming
up with a number of different strategies
to try to ensure that we could process
this as quickly as we possibly can and
as effectively as we can we've been
bringing in for example
individuals who still work for the
Department perhap perhaps were formally
an eligibility worker to work an
overtime project so that we are able to
make use of other resources in the
department that are willing to help us
with these efforts
we have strategies with respect to new
hires where we would train them first on
how to conduct redeterminations so that
they can focus solely on that we've
distributed or redistributed caseloads
so that we focus on this protected
population within one particular office
if you will so different ways that we're
trying to increase our own capacity it
also includes the procurement of a call
center so right now we have a current
temporary call center which contract
expires in June terrible timing for that
but we've been procuring a new call
center that we're adding a lot of
functionality to including being able to
conduct some of the Outreach and other
administrative processes for us and
we're wanting to stand that up by July
1st so that they are ready to answer the
phone by July 1st that process is going
well
um
staff have been
as I said earlier I'm very proud of them
having really facing this with the right
attitude that they've got this that
makes all the difference in the world so
I'm confident in them even though we're
a little bit apprehensive of not knowing
quite what to expect and we're going to
monitor and evaluate this constantly and
just see how it goes and where we may be
able to make some adjustments
follow up
so I appreciate all of that and and I'm
I'm just I'm oversimplifying this I I'm
really trying to understand is the
capacity that you have with all your
planning and everything
anticipated to be pegged out or do you
think you have additional flexibility in
your system for some other exigency to
think that you know we try to keep
some strategies in the back pocket if
you will
they be effective it's a bit unknown
this is really unpredictable so I can't
say that you know we are solid on how
this is going to go
um
I can tell you that we'll just do the
representative Weber could I ask the
same question a different way
um
do you feel you are adequately staffed
right now or understaffed right now uh
for both what you know today
and going forward into the future
I I believe that we are I think our if I
were to diagnose where I think we
um are concerned where we may need some
more resources and we're working on
putting together a plan there because
it's sort of where's our weak spot is on
the appeals and what we can do to
minimize you know in some cases there's
no basis for appealing so can we do
pre-resolution so that you know we're
not tying things up
um but I I do think that you know part
of how we're
all the pre-work that we've done in
other words all the voluntary activity
that we've been able to get the 32 000
people that did their redetermination
the 2400 people that have already let us
know and they're going to be more who
will let us know we don't have to go
through a full redetermination with that
the other thing I'd point out is that
the approximately 29 000 individuals who
have completed a redetermination that
are sort of front loaded because we know
they're ineligible they'll have a chance
to we'll we'll give them a notice and
they'll have a chance to update it but
based on what we have for information
we're not expecting them they don't have
to go through a full redetermination
process they they go through a process
that is will be less and so again having
done all that work with that group it's
not it's not a hundred thousand plus
that we need to do a full
redetermination on it's it's a smaller
group it's that 73 000. then when you do
it at a household level we're back down
you know 47 000 households which is
different than 73 000 people because
there's sort of a case head and we can
work it that way
um you know I feel like we're as
prepared as any state is out there if
not more
um and
um again I think the the area that I
feel we have some to strengthen and
we're working on it as we speak to is
getting ready for that pre-resolution
and and being able to handle appeal
volume if it materializes
and I think just spreading out the
distribution
over this you know 12-month period is
going to make a tremendous difference so
that is a really uh helpful
part of this plan uh that CMS had put
together for States because if we had to
do a little at once I would definitely
have more concerns but spreading it out
and strategically determining each month
which group we would look at is going to
make a tremendous difference for us
representative McDonald
good morning
I know historically having been having
worked for the Department there's
usually a number of vacant positions in
every division do you have a number of
maybe that's maybe that's an unfair
question I apologize if it is
I've been watching the vacancy rate
certainly in light of well regularly but
in light of this as well so for
eligibility staff right now it is at a
22 percent vacancy rate
okay and that they would determine the
eligibility for Medicaid and all that
type thing okay thank you
in in my area
um
I think I'm about 32 vacancy rate but in
terms of of this issue probably my my
deputy director left to take another
position outside of uh government who
was spearheading this for us um she we
have been working very closely with uh
and
um Deb sorley who's part of uh Karen's
team is taking that slice of the pie in
terms of standing up and keeping that
work going and we haven't lost a step
with her stepping into supporting us so
um we had some redundancy there
all right follow up so you said you have
a 32 vacancy rate in your in the
so um if I could just draw your
attention to the the bottom
um slide below the the percent of
population says monthly distribution of
individuals estimated if I take you to
the far right of the top chart I'm sorry
the the numbers are small here
um but we'll send it to you
electronically so you can increase it on
a PDF but if you notice uh like three
lines from the bottom a hundred and one
thousand seven ninety eight that was the
same number you saw earlier on when
there were the three boxes
um and then the numbers above that the
28 996 is again the same number when you
looked at individuals and the 72 802
which I've been rounding off to 73 000.
the same number you saw previously and
so what we're expecting overall based on
experience is that about just under 59
000 people who are currently in that
protected group will likely not remain
eligible and so if you take 60 000
roughly from where we are in terms of
current enrollment that's going to bring
us below 200 000 and then we have other
individuals who aren't going through
their normal distribution then the
normal workload of about 11 000
redeterminations a month we feel like
that we're gonna probably within a
year's time the 95 000 in granted
Advantage is going to look more like
sixty four thousand and get as we go
through another year we'll get back to I
think more where we were pre-pandemic if
you will in the 50 000s probably mid to
Upper depends on the economy how many
people you know um poverty levels were
just increased by the federal government
and all these numbers reflect running
the latest poverty numbers there were
about 1700 people who otherwise weren't
ineligible that benefited from the new
poverty levels that increased about
eight percent
um
so a lot of the rest of this is about
um what we've been doing
um
to uh again I think when you talked
about earlier Karen how you know people
have bought into what we're doing what
we really try to sort of message
internally is you know we don't want
anybody to lose coverage who shouldn't
lose coverage right and those that
aren't going to be able to remain on we
want to find if there is a different
source that they can get coverage for
example The Exchange we want to make
sure that they get connected to that
or if they're aging out of the program
make sure they get connected to Medicare
and so
again showing some
some initiative and Leadership I think
in the country we actually were the
first state to approach
the cons it's called socio which is an
abbreviation for
the the part of Health and Human
Services that oversees the
um the operation of the exchanges both
from the insurance companies and the and
looking for Consumer Protection
so for example someone who was over
income who did nothing with their
application just let it die off
ordinarily nothing would happen to them
they would just they would disappear
into the ether we worked actually to
develop an exchange
so someone may ordinarily apply for
Medicaid or ordinarily apply for
exchange covered correctly if they
qualify for one for example exchange
um and not Medicaid we send it to uh to
the to socio and if in Reverse they'll
send someone who may qualify for
Medicaid but these people who would
otherwise if you kind of think of a dead
letter box if you will if no one does
anything with their application who's
over income nothing happens and what
we've worked on as a process to exchange
that information back to them so that
they can work with the
um on a with The Navigators and however
they want to do it to make sure that
they're given the opportunity to apply
for for coverage and other mechanisms
one of the big messaging things that has
just come out of the
Consolidated appropriation Act is for
Medicare individuals and we do have
people that are aging out of Medicaid
that they have an open enrollment period
it's actually not just associated with
the the online but permanently now that
if you lose Medicaid in your Medicare
level you can have an open enrollment
period for six months but what we're
going to try to encourage people to do
because it's not good for the New
Hampshire Insurance Market or for the
individual don't don't wait for there to
be a gap in coverage before you do
something people who are on Medicaid
we'll have an opportunity to apply for
exchange coverage in a period that's
going to be a one-time period between
April 1 and July of 24 to apply for
exchange coverage again looking at
it for the benefit of the individual if
you get a car accident and you don't
have coverage you know you're going to
be in a hurting Place financially the
this new open enrollment period allows
someone if they know they're going to
lose coverage to 60 days in advance to
to apply get it all situated so they
um we've been working with the insurance
department we've been conversing with
the large insurers in the state that
like Anthem and Harvard Community Health
Plan about about the population that's
going to be coming off that may be their
future customers and and making sure
that they understand what's going on
talking to the New Hampshire health plan
which does the high-risk stuff to to
make sure that this transition not just
works for Medicaid but try to work make
it work for the insurance department and
for individuals and and the private
Market
um
and trying to be sensitive to the time
here this
um
some other information about like our
noticing
um on slide 27 you know we've we've gone
we went from what was just we started
off with pink letters
um to individuals so when we're trying
to get them to voluntarily do it sort of
a friendly kind of you know it's a good
thing to do on your own behalf you know
pre-plan and now we've converted to
yellow letters messaging and
um you know the detail that that we've
had to think about is for example
there's a national paper shortage and
you know making sure that we've got
supplies of paper and making sure simple
things like
um will our mail machine handle the
envelope that we intend to use because
we had an example where it didn't so
just
uh Logistics getting all those things
and making sure our mail room's situated
we have about uh is it close to 60
percent now of our enrollment have an
electronic mechanism so we have an
online account so we save Postage and
what have you and we're able to
communicate that way
um
and uh I guess maybe moving to the
this
slide 32 and 33
may be a good place to go here
um
they'll be certain
federal reporting requirements that were
embedded in the Consolidated
appropriation act and um slide 32 and 33
outline them and kind of our status
at the end of January in terms of being
able to handle all those things and and
we're we believe that we are but on top
of that uh the bottom of 34 going on to
to 35 is actually using our
technology we've we're going to have a
much more robust system of being able to
reporting on metrics because there's
going to be a lot of public interest in
in this and we're going to want to know
you know are there certain Geographic
areas or particular communities where
the this enrollment is higher than you
would expect it to be so that we can you
know take appropriate actions
and um let me just stop there I know
there's there's other things we want to
cover with you but uh
I think we hit the the highlights that
that you as legislators would probably
be interested in um and happy if you
want us to come back and give reports on
thank you and I'm this is I'm sure
covered somewhere but MSP under Medicaid
individuals by eligibility category what
does MSP stand for the Medicare
secondary plans the people who are like
our duels oh okay they have another
Insurance in addition to Medicaid you
mean yes okay
the poor elderly if you representative
Edwards uh thank you Mr chair so what I
think I heard you both say is you have
all the Manpower that you need to do
this program and when it's done in a
year you'll have excess capacity
sure I don't think you heard us say that
exactly I know because I couldn't get
um disrespectful whatever I mean we just
we've done the best planning we can we
know that
um you know turnover issues that we can
experience of a key person you know
we're not necessarily deep in in
different areas I think we're I think
we're ready to go I think the the other
thing too is have been Lessons Learned
in planning for this that I think we're
going to carry carry forward
um and also there's only so hard you can
push her eligibility team are going to
be asked to do almost the 50 increase in
their workload
um and you know was that sustainable
without pushing people out because they
get burnt out I think is another concern
that those last three sentences were
those that's what I was looking for okay
thank you you're you're going to bust
your butt for a year working 50 percent
extra capacity
and and then you're you're worried about
burnout during the course of the next
year
I want to lose any more people right
okay no this that was the answer I was
any other questions
[Music]
um and at that point you're still gonna
have
the rolling ongoing determinations
and although you may have more fewer
people coming off you still have
whatever the current volume of
applications to come on that you're
going to have to deal with
yes so
there's a lot more work that we're doing
besides Medicaid for eligibility of all
the other eligibility programs that of
course there's a concern of what's going
to get neglected
because of Medicaid unwind if anything's
going to get neglected so we can only
work with what we have and then trying
to be prepared for
worst case scenario if you will I mean
that's what this has been all about
but I I think if I may follow up I think
representative Edwards and I are both
trying to get at the same thing and
um I think that thing is if you think
you're going to need more people you
need to say so really loudly and clearly
to him because that's where the money
comes from
um and I'm sorry if I'm putting words in
your mouth and that that isn't what you
meant but that's sort of what I was
hearing
thank you uh year six continues with me
learning from you I need to figure out
how to just say tell me if you need more
money that's really where I was going
and and and I also assume or I will just
say from my perspective
although I want you to have the people
you need if we can find them which is
the whole other issue I also don't want
to throw money at a problem if it's not
going to be useful money thrown usefully
at a problem but I I also Mr Mr chairman
if I would love to hear an update in
maybe not a month but maybe three months
or at whatever interval the committee
deems best because the the thing that I
want to keep my eye on as well as
whether you have reached the end of your
elasticity and something's going to snap
but I'm I'm hearing your concern about
the appeals process and I think we want
to keep our eye really carefully on that
so I don't know what the best reporting
schedule is my thought would be three
months I've already asked Mr lippman to
come back every month that we meet even
if it's a brief report or sometimes a
long report and he says this is his
favorite group of people and all of them
so uh of course he'll come back don't
you have to say that
um thank you he doesn't have to he
graciously did though okay
thank you I would say also too that
um you know we've gone out and talked to
like the Congressional office the
governor's office in terms of the people
who might get uh constituent issues and
we do want to you know sometimes someone
there's a lot of unique circumstances
and sometimes we I think we've tried to
plan for every contingency of those
unique circumstances but you know if you
hear of constituents that having a
problem or something's not working right
we want to hear about it so you can help
us in that regard and
um appreciate it absolutely
is it likely you're going to be coming
and talk to us about teeth
but what I'm sorry Dental oh
yeah just just before noon okay
may I just add you may
I just
the question on the Staffing and I I
heard that you were trying to ask this
question and Karen's being very gracious
in her answer but we are 22 aggregate
right so in in Karen's and Henry trumps
Karen with the 32 to the 22 right our
nurses trumpet at 64 percent
um we're robbing Peter to pay Paul to do
this work right so we're paying overtime
we're doing comp time I'm pulling people
that do other tasks have done it in the
past to come do that so we have so many
open positions so it's not about adding
positions necessarily and part of our
goal is to try to fill those positions
and as we do we burn out the people
doing the 50 more right so so I guess
the the ask would be in terms of
understanding the process and the work
that we're doing and that we may we may
fall behind we may have complaints but
we're doing what we can with the
resources that we have so I just you
know Karen's getting very uh creative
with how we do that but at the end of
the day I do worry that we're going to
be 32 percent in at the end of this year
so I just wanted to add that the
previous Lori told me about a job fair
and around and how did that work out
we're constantly doing job fairs I mean
we just had an item approved to to get
some additional software tools so
recruitment is constant Innovation is
constant going to schools I mean never
mind job fairs I mean we're on the
street corner I mean we're everywhere we
can get to ask people to work come work
for us I'm being sarcastic with the
street corner my point is we're
everywhere
um that does explain a sign I saw though
okay
so I was going to talk to you about the
dress code on the street corner but
[Laughter]
I was going to ask how your pay compared
with legislative salary but
you know and that's a real I'll be
honest with you wages are a real a real
Challenge and we're trying through
through our department of administrative
services to get a new system up that
will bring us up to some levels but
unfortunately that takes a little bit of
time and that's time that's gonna that's
not gonna impact from a year this is
happening now so
still have time for us I have some we
have some time
okay um have the dental update uh-huh
could I just ask one more question
before you do the dental update sure
you know I keep wrestling with this
problem of Workforce
shortages which I I see everywhere I go
that's no news to anybody in this room
some concept and this is for a different
committee other than the one I normally
sit on
but I keep hearing you know you've got a
22 percent Gap
and these are are positions that are
currently funded they're just not filled
and I keep wondering if that couldn't be
shifted somehow via the budget or some
other mechanism or reclassification or
something to
fewer funded positions but having those
positions funded
at a higher level
using the funding that's already
allocated
and this is clearly a question coming
from somebody who doesn't work with this
all of the time and I just throw it out
there if that's if that's something you
think about or and I don't desperately
need an answer I just wanted to kind of
throw it out there because it sounds
like if if we could get you by offering
higher wages for the positions that are
open to a 10 percent Gap
that might
take some of the strain off at least
that's a great question it's a strategy
that we've considered to like even
temporary enhancements to those
positions while you're doing
um the some of this this work for some
of the staff
um that the reclassification system that
Das is working on is is doing that is
bringing elevating up eligibility
positions they're probably one of the
lowest paid positions that we have with
the most complex work that needs to get
done it's not necessarily easy to
determine eligibility there's a skill
set there so yeah we are we are working
on that for sure okay great thank you
much
so the next report we have is on the
adult Dental benefit and you know we're
just a little bit over a month away when
we're looking to begin we have to get as
part of the legislative mandate to to
have the The Denture benefit available
only to
um the waiver population and people in
nursing homes as well as the cost
sharing we had to do a number of
different waivers they're all in motion
we've
feel in a good place that we're going to
get them in place by the end of March so
that we can begin April 1st that being
said I think our biggest challenge is
the sort of the network development and
that's our we're focusing on that we've
had some good wins there in terms of
um in particular oral surgery has been a
hard thing to fill and we've been able
to get a good group of oral surgeons
in so far and uh
um
the Northeast Delta Dental and
DentaQuest their subcontractor
um are are working on other strategies
to try to you know fill in I think
certainly by April 1st
um you know the health conditions that
um you know require immediacy will be
able to be handled and will be I think
ramping up the the preventative uh
aspect of it
um but I think we'll be in a in a a
place where we have enough that we'll be
given the green light from CMS to to
continue that and I I promise to keep
you informed if it's different than that
um you know we are again on the edge in
terms of we didn't have a long time to
stand this up but we think we're going
to get there and that's what I think
it's reflected here on the report
are there Geographic gaps in the people
who are coming forward to be providers
there there are some Geographic things
that we need to work on
um and
um I have one of my staff leads is is
sort of running this so I'm not as
informed exactly what they are but in
terms of just general updates I know
that those are things we're trying to
fill out and that's where I think
Northeast Delta Dental and that the
quest of coming up with potentially some
other things to offer dentists to
encourage them to to sign on
would you expand on that I I know I've
had this conversation with you a few
times and also with Tom Raphael of Delta
Dental in terms of incentivizing
um
what are you doing that seems to be
getting results
I think up to this point it's been sort
of appeared appeared it's you know we've
it's been something that the state and
people have had an interest in adult
Dental to stand up and there's been a
lot of push there and the second thing
is I think that
um
people under getting people to
understand who are in the dental
profession the extra wraparounds that
you know the worst thing a dentist has
is an empty chair you know that you know
what what type of supports are there and
I think the probably the last level is
is there some economic things that uh
Delta Dental and dentaquist can offer to
to uh to encourage some other folks to
to sign up and that that's kind of
they're working through those thoughts
at the moment some Financial
incentivization
yep some you know the the fee schedules
an enhanced fee schedule but you know um
you know other other things to get them
to do the enrollment part of it do you
have anything I speak as one who is
desperately short of pcps in our family
practice uh
just can't find them and so we're now
um
going to a med school and saying we'll
help you with your tuition but you owe
us and doing that sort of thing is that
under consideration for uh people in
dental school so we do have the loan
repayment program already in place we
also Dr Finney can speak more to this
we've in terms of connecting with the
dental schools I think there was an
article I read this past week that talks
about this a hundred thousand shortage
of dentists around the country so I mean
we're it it is a difficult situation the
other thing is what can be done in terms
of
tele-dentistry for for screenings and
what can be done in terms of using
extenders if you will in terms of trying
to get to the preventative things I
think those are all
strategies that that are being looked at
is there a dental equivalent of a nurse
practitioner
um
I think that's a little bit outside my
say equivalent but there are individuals
who can do some of a preventative work
that does require ultimately I think a
dentist to come by and and
professionally to to supervise what was
was done but you can extend the dentist
that'd be a good thing to work on
perhaps for future legislation because
we have been authorizing various steps
between here and here over the years and
this might be a hopeful thing yeah there
are some professions that are trying to
advocate
that would require professional
licensure changes in our state to to be
able to accommodate okay and the other
questions uh representative Weber I'll
start with a comment I know the
independent practice of dental
hygienists is something that's been an
issue ongoing and I'm not sure the
status right now because it's been a
while since I was on knee DNA but that
has been this under discussion for at
least the last 10 years or so
but if I made the question I wanted to
ask is I have heard some feedback and it
wasn't direct to me so I don't know
otherwise I would have had people come
direct to
you uh but in the context of
um eye care
I know that there was somebody who
expressed real concern about how long it
took to be reimbursed like six months
for Eye Care and
if if you're the only if if you're the
only practitioner that does it and
you're also having to wait that long to
be reimbursed
I'm wondering if
uh and maybe outside of the scope of
what we're doing here today to talk
about those gaps but I'm hoping that
there
that you're building mechanisms in place
so that the people who do actually sign
up
get paid in a timely manner because
otherwise they won't resign and then
you'll be in a bigger pickle so so we do
have a contractual time frames in which
they have to pay claims and
I know one of members of the committee
referred to me
a practice that I need to we missed each
other because they went on vacation
right after but I do need to finish
following up with them but you know
people shouldn't encourage you if you
hear anybody that's not getting paid
within 30 days want to hear about it
okay so so 30 days is the basic
expectation yes
a clean claim meaning that it's got all
the information
right representative Edwards uh thank
you Mr chair uh we uh at the kickoff of
this term I was in on a presentation by
a UNH demographer who
um had all kinds of great statistics
about the layout of uh the demographics
in our state and one of the areas of
special interest to me were those
Pockets where we had
um a a disproportionate percentage of of
uh poverty I'll just go with poverty and
often that poverty was also associated
with the race or ethnicity but but in a
in a map of New Hampshire there were
like
four or five you know discernible
pockets and I'm just wondering uh as I
hear you talk about the gaps in the
provider network if there's any
intentional mapping of where our gaps
are to where we have potential Health
inequalities to ensure that we're doing
what we can specifically to to make sure
that our Health Care system is balanced
and evenly distributed do you get what
I'm saying there I believe I do and
there actually are what they
you know the Health Resource Services
Administration Again part of the federal
has actually mapped out what they called
um professional shortage areas dentist
is one Mental Health Providers or
Another Part of of dealing with some of
the the if you if you kind of look at I
have a map
um I think in the slide deck that I'll
review with the at your committee on
Monday but just showing kind of where
the different enrollment is in that
unfortunately like where the population
is
is smaller it tends to be more of those
challenges which makes it difficult for
practice to have the size and the
turnover to be you know successful and
it's you kind of think about
um
managing your mix of who you're going to
serve in other words you know it's very
hard for a practice that's relying
totally on Medicaid to survive and a
practice that has a higher commercial
balance of patients you know that's
people tend to locate where they're
going to get attract a customer base if
you will or patient base where they can
balance it out where they can
uh make up make a living if you will and
serving and I'm you know it looks like
you want to say something about that
chairman oh yeah
seeing the report come across my desk
every week I know roughly how many
Medicaid people we can take even though
we are a faith-based non-profit and this
is part of our mission statement that
piece of paper does not give adequate
payment to my staff so I know how much
we can do and we are willing to do more
if our reimbursement rate was realistic
so I said that to just about everybody
including a lot of people who don't care
okay so I think what I'm asking if I had
an ask is as you're looking at the the
the Gap in your network if you find a
correlation between the Gap and the
network and these pockets of a
particular in inequality would you
please make it a special effort to
report to the to the this committee
with your permission so that we are
aware if we've if we've got a gap in
what we're trying to do to proactively
manage the Gap away
in in those particular areas where we
have a disproportionate poverty
thank you I have um another piece in
terms of a couple of pieces that uh
all right Mr Edwards would be happy to
pass Mr Williams would be happy to pass
he's even buttoning his suit jacket
which is what you do when you approach
never
so I just
um
wanted to share some
it's coming around is this color chart
I'll talk about in a minute there's uh
some uh statistics that the Kaiser
Family Foundation puts together about
every state and the US on on Medicaid
this report was dated October 22nd
um of 22 excuse me October of 2022
um and I'll just I want to hit on a
couple points here there's also the
United States average
one thing I would share with you
um
and I'll there's also a link here that
New Hampshire as a state has the fourth
lowest Medicaid enrollment in the
country
um so while it feels like you know and
it is true that we have had a
significant increase in in enrollment
um where the fourth lowest out of 50
states in Medicaid enrollment
um sort of the the
the percent of population that's low
income and the percent of population at
the top of the the chart there
that are covered by Medicaid today in
the country it's almost one in three
people are covered by Medicaid based on
the continuous coverage in New Hampshire
it's about one in five and a half
individuals
um
the other interesting statistic I think
you might find
on the bottom right is and I mentioned
this when I was at a senate hearing this
week is that 70 of the people on
Medicaid in New Hampshire are working
um that's higher than the national
average and compared to New Hampshire in
2019 I think we're at 65 percent in 2019
um
and then you know just I won't go over
everything here but it just if you want
to compare how many
um you know adults we cover along the
bottom left there there's the number of
adults that we we cover is one in ten
you can compare that to the U.S
um and you know children nursing home
residents
Medicare beneficiaries and probably most
of the categories
um New Hampshire is probably a little
bit less than the national
um
um it kind of is I think a the top chart
left-hand chart shows enrollment versus
expenditures and as you would expect you
know there are certain populations that
we enroll that
um you know the older people the people
who are on waivers we spend more money
proportionally per enrollee it's not
necessarily a surprise but it's just I
think a nice graph that shows it
um
and then
if you look at uh sort of two-thirds
down on the left hand side you know 24
of the births in New Hampshire are
covered by Medicaid you know but there's
you know where we've seen some stresses
where that can be 50 in some parts of
the state or more and so that you know
when you talk about kind of where things
are located and and stressor is what
we've seen you know and and the
legislature did some intervention in
terms of approving more money for
maintaining maternity care in hospitals
and birthing centers
um can I ask you in terms of this sure
pie chart 24 of births
I with four grandchildren one was quick
the other was slow but still it took
place over a very brief period of time
does this mean they were covered
pre-birth
postpartum how long or just the day they
were born which I don't believe but yeah
now I don't know that this chart does
that level of degradation if you will in
terms of when that coverage kicked in
one thing I would say about New
Hampshire is if you look at compared to
the National numbers we have more
generous eligibility criteria for
children and so you know in terms of uh
you know taking care of kids in terms of
providing coverage I think you know we
stand out in terms of having
better eligibility levels than some
other states
and we're working hard on those
postpartum periods
in fact
I think I have uh so the the other Pages
if you want to just compare to to the
United States and
um if you're interested in any other
state it's easy to send you a link and
you can do a comparison
um the next grouping what are two maps
one is the postpartum coverage map I
know that the house took up uh
postpartum coverage
um
Annapolis
there's one more handout yeah you have
taught me the law
okay
sorry pull a lot of order here
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair this is this is just an editorial
comment
um I I realized that the Kaiser Family
Foundation is a separate entity and one
of the things I do is they track
politics but for a handout from the
government this in the on the second
page bottom left corner yes associating
political viewpoints with support for
Medicaid I this this is probably
inappropriate for a government policy
perspective but
that's my point of view I know you
didn't produce it I just I'm just
warning you that this probably isn't
something that ought to be on materials
okay
foreign
and the
the two maps one is sort of as of
February 10th uh kind of what's going on
in the country in terms of uh States on
that matter and then
um on the
the second map is the the Medicaid
expansion
um there are now 39 States plus uh uh DC
that are have adopted the latest state
is South Dakota which is in the
implementation phase and this this is
just
because I know you're looking at these
issues I thought you might like to have
these two two things
um but I I sort of uh
sort of a punchline document here just
some observations that I would make at
one at which I began my conversation
with saying that you know only New
Hampshire is the fourth lowest
um I gave you the link if you want to
check that out and
look at that the
the other thing that I think is
impressive and if you think of Medicaid
not just as a loan but how it works with
the rest of the insurance markets that
um New Hampshire ranked number one in
the country in terms of employer covered
insurance which again I think is is a
good thing in terms of
employer-sponsored coverage
um in part I think when you look at the
the Medicaid Program in terms of how
what risks it manages and what the what
the exchange manages I think that's
helps the health of our market and then
um we covered that point in terms of the
percent of people
um working but number four
um this sort of my own personal
observation of excuse me is this a new
apartment
control
so
the perspective I would say is you're
thinking about it from a policy
perspective Medicaid's part of the the
I think the functioning of the insurance
markets but when you look at the 1332
waiver that the insurance department
obtained to help manage risk and you
look at moving Medicaid expansion out of
the exchange and back into the Managed
Care Program
that the health of New Hampshire's
Insurance Market
you know the Benchmark premium on the
exchange was the lowest in the country
we used to be higher but I think the
combination of policy levers that have
been pulled in the state
um have put us in a pretty good position
um
and that you know in addition we're
seeing a higher percentage of the
Medicaid Program working so if if you
look at things that you'd like to have
come out of all these different policy
levers I think you can be proud of
legislatively what and you know from a
Department's perspective both insurance
and and and others
that that we're healthcare is expensive
I'm not trying to say it's not but I
think in terms of relative to other
states positions we have something to be
proud about here we more people working
than average you know lower Benchmark
premium and a higher in the highest
actually employer sponsored coverage in
the country so
could we infer that because there is
Health Care to some degree available to
more people
those people are going to be healthier
and more likely to have and keep a job
yes I think that is an inference I would
I would take from this okay
representative Weber one quick question
is you were talking about managing
the costs with respect to levers you
said
the one thing I want to be sure of if
we're looking at these numbers and
they're
real reasons to be self-congratulatory
are we comparing Apples to Apples in
that we are comparing the same level of
benefits across the states because we
know that you know there are a lot of
programs that some states adopt some
states don't adopt so I'm just wondering
if if that
discrepancy or not discrepancy if that
variation has been factored into the
numbers here
in terms of The Benchmark premium yes on
that okay that is that is um
that is a national
standard in terms of what you offer on
Exchange is there's a 10 essential
benefits and it's it's a specific so
this is the basic package the basic
package
I guess the most common purchase one is
what they use okay because I just if if
what we're doing is saving money because
we're not providing the same services or
if we're not providing adequate Services
that's not a reason to congratulate
ourselves but if we're comparing to the
same bundle of basic Services then
but I think it looks really good
Medicaid when you've seen one state
you've seen one state there are
commonalities but you know I think again
the fact that we're seeing you know
comparing 2019 to 2022 and we're seeing
more people working
that's that's a good thing I can't say
it's because of this or that but it just
is and you know it's it's uh the the
numbers that are behind that Workforce
numbers are not numbers produced by
Kaiser their numbers produces through
the federal government Bureau of Labor
Statistics and one other Bureau that
and part of the census I think that
and uh
the only other thing that I had if you
still have time for me was the chairman
asked me to and
um
to look at rate setting a little bit and
I
um also know that the chairman
um
division three wants me to do some too
and I have something here today that
there's a lot of work to to developing
this but I think the concept was you
know looking at targeted rate setting
versus across the board and I have some
material here to
that won't answer all the questions it's
a beginning of I think the process
um but uh let me just walk through some
representative Edwards for a question
while the document's being passed out so
Mr Lipman do you want to introduce us as
as the 80 20 first cut or disclaim what
we're about to look at
I would say that
um the 80 20 is in part you'll see me
raise that a bit but it's not I guess a
full 80 20 maybe as as you fully maybe
envisioned but it begins to get to that
um it's just in terms of
um there's a lot of data work that needs
to be done and I've done as much as I
could get out of the various resources I
have to to to do that and I just I could
what I want to do is today is present
um sort of some Concepts
um and and share some data
so the fir if uh slide one
um is sort of uh
I guess my overview of what you would
expect to see and rate setting in terms
of just rates in general that you know
generally Medicaid rates
um where it's possible usually expressed
as a percentage of Medicare Medicare
being a system that's intended for
reasonably efficient provider to cover
full costs Medicaid generally covers a
percentage of full costs
um all when it doesn't cover variable
cost and only covers a little bit of
full cost is when as the chairman talks
about it you have to manage how many
patients you accept or accept at all
um
and then commercial rates are typically
for facilities or two times Medicare for
Physician Services about one and a half
times that though that relationship of
one and a half times doesn't necessarily
follow through when you get like at
Physical Therapy ambulances and other
things in our state
um and that
um you know the within the Medicaid
Program
um to cover all the drugs and everything
that we we have on our charge Master if
you will there's 13 000 codes but using
the 80 20 Rule and
um and if you jump to
um
um let's see the last uh
let's see yeah
actually
for those of us who are ignorant could
you just explain what the 80 20 rule is
sure
um the Pareto Principle
um is basically that typically uh 20 of
something can describe 80 of what you're
you're going at and so you know
um in terms of
um of the 13 000 codes as an example and
um
that
about 100 codes explained about 80 of
our spending
or in waiver Services maybe 142 codes
billing codes uh you know represent
about 80 percent of our spending thank
you um and
you know I don't think we have time to
go through sort of a code level but um
do you know that my dog giving Comfort
to scared people in the waiting room is
not a billing code because we looked I I
believe you and other other things
um
it's sort of like how when you're doing
targeted rate setting how you might go
about looking at it
um so you know if I sort of put it in
steps here is that I think the first
thing you look at is how does the rate
that you're paying compared to Medicare
or if it's a cost reimburse Services how
does it compare to allowable Medicaid
costs that's I think the first thing but
that's not the only thing you have to
look at again I think we also tend to
look at other states rates to see what
they're they're paying but that
sometimes doesn't tell the whole story
either
then where it starts to come into a less
more subjective because we don't have
hard data on this up
um is you know are we seeing access
issues
um you know in for example in private
duty nursing we're only able to fulfill
60 of of the um uh the hours that are
assessed by a physician as an example
um you know based on the Staffing that's
available you know we have we've all
read a lot about the Mental Health
crisis in terms of how long it takes to
to uh to get an appointment if it's not
a crisis situation
um
then you know a fourth factor is you
know the the number of Medicaid patients
or the percentage of your revenue or
percentage of your patient base that you
can afford to serve
um
then
looking at the financial status of the
provider type you know
um some some providers have a little bit
more that they're less dependent on
Medicaid or maybe larger and get certain
economies than others I'd you know
describe for example I think
some provider types are are like the
subsistent farmers you know they're just
barely making it there's no real
reserves there and then I think the
other factor that we've talked about
today is
you know
is there the workforce shortage issues
are um and so I think you have to look
at these issues together
um sort of
um
a holistic approach of what you're
representative Edwards
uh thank you Mr chair I'm looking at
step four and I'm I'm just trying to
think through the rationale of of why
it's uh a concern of Medicaid to look at
a percentage of revenue from both the
Medicaid and an uncompensated care
perspective is it is it Our obligation
is the state's obligation to worry about
managing the uncompensated care levels
at a given facility
it serves exclusively or near
exclusively Medicaid and they have a lot
of uncompensated care their ability to
stay around because they're not getting
full cost on anything and if we're
depending on that provider type is the
issue
is is to what extent is the amount of
uncompensated care a local provider
decision is are they mandated to provide
a hundred percent of the Care under
their uncompensated care
program or or I I'm just trying I it's
been so long I looked at uncompensated
care I'm just trying to re-remember
the flexibility the providers have in
accepting that
so so some of it may be just better
described as bad debt like the you know
person has a high deductible plan and
you know they have you know they owe a
hundred dollars or a thousand dollars or
five thousand dollars on a bill and you
know do they make that that payment and
um so I think that it's a again
um
in
our nursing home reimbursement and our
Hospital reimbursement in the state we
do take into account directly
on uncovered costs and so I think we do
have an interest but ultimately the
interest boils down to can the people
you know are we providing a compliant
program where people have access to the
benefit that we're paying a premium for
through the insurer but that that I
think is
um you know like
substance use disorder provider one
provider for example might accept all
comers and if that provider is going to
go down the drain and we're going to
lose complete access to say high level
substance use disorder Services we do
have to take an interest in that to
ensure that the person can people can
continue to be served it's not as I say
it's not like a mathematical calculation
it's a
it's sort of a factor in in looking at
the the rate that when you're targeting
rates what you should potentially do
I know in my facility we look at bad
debt
and we try to look at it as
compassionately as we can
and there's very good reasons why very
good people sometimes can't pay their
bills and we very often will carry those
people to the degree we have good
insurance people paying
we also have the right to discharge a
patient in 30 days you can come to us
for the next 30 days but after that 30
days you're out you are not our patient
and we've had to do that rarely
other people other facilities may have a
different standard of when they boot
people for bad debt
the third page in is
um
again in terms of the time frame I had
to sort of work on things working with
some existing data is looking at some
major groupings of of codes in terms of
what percent of Medicare
um based this is not managed care data
this is just what we're paying under
FIFA service what percent of Medicare
are we are we paying so generally you
would hope to see
something and in a let's say a
diversified provider you know
I think it's between 60 and 80 percent
would be considered that you're covering
variable costs and and some of fixed
costs in some areas you'll see we we pay
more than that and there's reasons to do
so but it's it's starting to look at
what categories where we may need to to
look at certain things and the bottom
one I'll explain in a moment but this is
kind of where we are today in terms of
looking at our FIFA service schedule
against the Medicare fee schedule you
can see in a lot of areas you know below
60 percent
um
and the bottom one is really again a
it's a very small area and it's it's the
where the that number is high is related
to supplies
not on ambulance services I'll show you
ambulance in a little bit
um
but again this is only a very small
number and we're only talking FIFA
service here and in part sometimes
because you know they've been years in
some cases decades between being able to
adjust fee schedules that some things
get out of out of whack and being able
to do a targeted approach allows us to
um going to the fourth slide
there are some Services we pay on a cost
basis and
um
and these uh the numbers that we're
looking at here are don't include any
supplemental payments or or additional
payments made outside of the the
payments here but basically this is
a group of facilities that are based on
a cost basis you might house members in
particular might zero in on nursing
facilities County providers
that we make two additional payments on
top of the what is 48 of cost is what
the what the daily rate reimbursement
amounts to but we also make uh based on
the the provider tax that nfq excuse the
nfqa tax
that's assessed we make a payment and
then we also make the pro share payment
on top of that
again when you look at
um you know the county providers are
serving almost you know approaching 80
percent
um private providers 61 percent the
private providers do not get a uh
just excuse me a pro share payment
and then state-owned facilities
um where we're trying to get it up to
cost is basically what the what you see
there there are some costs that aren't
aren't allowed
um
the the next slide is just an example of
something that I'm sorry yes
representative Weber
I'm just trying to this is an area that
I just am not at all familiar with so
um I hope you'll pardon my ignorance but
I I'm looking at the fact that the
county providers are
um
at
a base
base rate of forty percent eight percent
of allowable cost
um
and
I'm wondering why there's so much
difference between that and the private
facilities and what that all means
because I'm really ignorant in this area
and if if it's just me I'll I'll back
off and have that conversation outside
of everybody else's time but
um we're all pretty concerned about our
County nursing homes
um
County facilities right I think we would
recognize Often by The Last Resort in
terms of accepting a patient so
in many instances the the mix of people
that they have to accept or do accept
may have a
higher intensity of need of service it
could be not necessarily that they're
sicker but they may need more supports
yep
right so then the what what the 48
represents is the daily rate so if
you're if you're accepting patients that
are more costly to serve if you will the
cost that the county facilities have
um
you would expect that
um they would cost more
um and that the rate would be less
sufficient
um so then what we do for all nursing
facilities we try to make up some of the
difference between costs through the the
tax program and the the extra match that
we draw and pay out to all facilities
and then for the counties because they
have that sort of adverse situation we
make the pro share payment on top of
that so I don't have didn't have time to
to calculate what that all would look
like but that's just a
show you why in one instance we if we
didn't take into account
the pair mix of the counties and do
something extra we wouldn't have
probably County nursing facilities no I
understand I understand the mix I just
didn't understand how this statistic
related to it so thank you
um
the next example is um
related to private duty nursing and
um
licensed practical nurses in the state
plan in terms of we had some concerns
expressed to us about you know and as I
mentioned to you we have uh trouble
meeting all the hours that patients have
been assessed for and you know we did
some comparisons with other states here
and
um
uh this is probably something that we
did probably about a year ago and and
when you look at the sum total of it
when we compare ourselves to like
Vermont and Maine and
um
um Rhode Island
um you know we're we're pretty
competitive there but we're also hearing
from that that provide a class that
they're stressed stressed in providing
services and
um you know we see a big gap in coverage
um again
um
this is sort of a judgment call in terms
of targeting rate increases you know
because if you're not providing adequate
Home Care people end up
institutionalized which is a much more
expensive way for the state to pay for
meeting their needs so it's kind of
that's a it's a balancing act
um this is sort of an unresolved one at
um
the next one
is ambulance
and this is one where you where the
legislature approved moving the rates
from
you look at the the blue heading columns
the rates that existed prior to
the legislature's actions that we were
running
you know depending on the service as low
as 22 percent of Medicare and up to you
know 38 was the high
here the commissioner and I have
received phone calls that
um
that nursing homes and hospitals are
having difficulty
getting
either patients to appointments for
medical appointments through uh and also
transfers between hospitals you know
just this week I got another complaint
that
um from three nursing facilities that
the provider that's been helping them
get patients to hospitals that they're
they're basically saying to them we
can't serve you anymore we don't have
enough staff to do it we've got to
manage our payer mix and we're going to
um then you know so the the 50 increase
um is in the orange you know kind of
where we stand today but you know again
when you look across
at other states
um we're still lagging there and and you
know
um
it's it's an issue I think that uh
um when patients can't get transferred
um you know those costs get passed down
to municipalities who who have to
um you know maybe use their fire
department to transfer or they have to
pay additional money it's it's an issue
that I think we all need to be concerned
about
um so again I think
um Workforce shortage inability to meet
patients needs is something that we're
um
then um I think the last example I want
to share with you
um was uh hospice care
and this is one where we're paying
slightly more than Medicare and we're
kind of pushed into that
um and that maybe it's not a bad thing
because of of concerns about people who
need hospice treatment but having to
apply across the board sometimes leads
in a result where maybe part of that
money could have been better used
somewhere else
and so and then the last two pages are
some work that started to do in terms of
looking at where our spend is
um in
um and paying claims this is only claims
for comparing 22 to to 19
um just two years that we have sort of
complete information on so the
pre-pandemic year
calendar year 19 and
um sort of coming out of the pandemic 22
in terms of where
where the dollars are in terms of
um you know when we need to make rate
adjustments I do have some other
exhibits that are
I think I'll save to when I get to
fiscal committee that looks at that that
80 20 kind of concept in terms of which
codes you know get to
um you know the big account for a large
percentage of the spend and as I said I
think
I'm a professional category I can fit
them all on one page pretty small and
get up to 80 and on on the waiver
programs I don't even need a full page
and I can get to 100
um
so I think there's hopefully some of
this information is is helpful I know
it's not all you want it's not all that
I that I can produce it's just what I
could produce in the time frame I'm
sorry
yes representative okay uh thank you
this is far more than we had just a few
days ago when we were hearing 3.1
percent across the board so now we're I
think we're starting to think here and
this is good so
um is is one of your one of your
takeaways that maybe if we're looking to
rebalance the 3.1 percent and I mean we
could just make it bigger right we could
make it 5.1 percent theoretically but
but if we kind of wanted to stay within
a 3.1 percent pot and we wanted to
redistribute from one side of the pot to
the other
or did I did I hear you write to imply
that maybe our Hospice Services could
help
uh
fund or reallocate from hospice and to
some of these other categories without
doing damage to the hospice
it just purely looking at as as a rate
issue if if if Medicaid is generally
supposed to just not pay more than
Medicare the answer I guess would be yes
I I don't know enough I haven't spent
enough time to understand the whole
hospice situation and how it fits with
home care agencies which may be
stressing on another side
um follow-up so okay so pretending for a
moment I'm not holding it you to it but
just for the purposes of the
conversation but I think you're getting
it so so if we find that hospice could
potentially be a place where we could
free up some money to reallocate
somewhere else which of these categories
because you have about eight slides
would where do you think is the most
critical that we may want to fund more
on a more urgent basis
well I think in terms of looking at it
from the Medicaid Program perspective I
think
probably mental health issues substance
use disorder issues ambulance issues is
that one of the slides you're saying
words that I don't think we just
reviewed on any of these slides they're
they're Professional Services of
that are um
that when we look get down to a code
level in that grouping you'll see
um
could you refer to a page tell me what
page it's not on a not on a page what
I'm saying is when you
I gave you a broad category if we drill
down to the code level like you can look
at
um those types is that the kind of
information on the other two sheets that
you're bringing to the division three
thank you
and I think I've overstayed my welcome
but uh I know there's one more report
all done thank you um I think you had
149 that you also wanted to get reported
but yeah we can do it 149 a little bit
Yeah okay
um thank you for the opportunity and
appreciate a chance to Cheers
I don't know Johnny Williams come up
here
hello
my name is Karen Hebert again from the
division of economic stability and I
just wanted to actually take 15 seconds
could you be a little closer to the
microphone please
thank you I just wanted to take 15
seconds and introduce to you my new
deputy director for the division Tina
Cabana I just wanted to would you spell
that please
welcome
welcome Angie you are deputy director
of
the division of economic stability good
welcome
and good morning my name is Don Tierney
I'm a Medicaid policy administrator for
so we are happy to provide you with this
uh would be the final report in
accordance with Senate Bill 149
um
and happy to answer any particular
yeah
we'll give it about 30 seconds so they
foreign
Mr chairman
representative Edwards is first and then
and you may go
I I just want a uh a one sentence
definition of what the term spend down
means
that's when an individual has too much
like for a granite Advantage so they
have to then incur medical expenses
before Medicaid and once they meet that
income level Medicaid will then begin to
pay
um for any claims they're in fee for
service and the spend down will
generally have to be met every month
unless they're on a six-month period
representative
Weber
well I'm asking this because I know that
the honorable Ken snow would want me to
um does this mean that we
how how far have we progressed towards
his goal of
upping the limits
at which the spend down
has to start or or at the way the upping
the limits at which the spend down ends
um and making it easier for the people
both the people who are subject to the
spend down as individuals and
in particular the mental health centers
who have to eat
the amount that can't be paid for until
the spend down happens I know his
objective was closing that Gap and I'm
wondering how this report fits with that
this report doesn't really have anything
to do with increasing the um we call it
the pill the protected income limit
effective January 1st of this year the
income limit for a household size of one
increase to 888 dollars where prior to
seeing none thank you well I I actually
do I think
um
thank you
yes
I'm just trying to absorb this
um
so what I think I'm reading here
more than half of the people who are
don't have to actually submit the
medical expenses every month how do you
so what this is actually saying is due
to the um
continuous eligibility enrollment during
the covid-19 federal Public Health
Emergency they don't have to submit
their bills we do it systematically for
anybody who met their spend down on or
after March 18th of 2020.
um but once that continuous eligibility
requirement ends then they will start
have to submitting the bills for the
spend down okay well that answered my
darn
not everyone's favorite program I was
going to say
and we we miss representative snow a
great deal because he kept his eyes
firmly on that particular ball yes and
I'm glad to report that we were able to
get it increased for helpful meeting his
objective
seeing or nearing no further questions
thank you so much thank you
just a word to the committee our next
meeting is March 24th fourth Friday of
the month at 10 A.M we will have a
report from the interim commissioner and
from Mr Lipman we will be given reports
that we need to hear
and the final item is one or more things
that the committee would like to hear
this is the opportunity where we might
have a question about something and with
advanced notice we can ask the relevant
Department people to come to be with us
and this is something that I work with
um attorney Williams with is shaping the
next agenda so if you've got some ideas
please give them to me you see he can do
many many things besides pass out paper
and does them well and we shape the
agenda each month he tells me what to
think I think accordingly and we're both
happy
so let me know and we yes senator
um I want to go back and revisit the
Quorum for this meeting I pulled up the
RSA while I was sitting here it's three
Senators five house members plus two
alternates so that would be eight
members and therefore the Quorum would
have been five okay if I'm incorrect I'm
I was just taking the number
as a follow-on to that
Mr chairman I note that on our on the
website
we only have one member who is listed as
an alternate
well I know we have too and so we need
well there are 10 people named and I